welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
Islam and sauna the D Willis James
professor of missions and world
Christianity at the Yale Divinity School
a professor of history and the director
of the project on religious freedom and
society in Africa at the Macmillan
Center he is the author of more than 200
articles on religious and historical
subjects and of several books including
disciples of nations pillars of world
Christianity today we'll talk with
Professor Sanne about his new book
Beyond jihad
welcome professor sana thank you I'm
delighted to be here let's begin with an
overview of your book tell us about it
well the book beyond jihad is about the
story of a pacifist movement in West
African Islam that started eight nine
hundred years ago and my interest in the
subject is to try and discover what held
the group together over such a long
period of time they rejected jihad and
how did they survive the threat of jihad
when they came upon it and in the
process I was also interested in
accounting for the history of the Mali
Empire which is one of the most
spectacular kingdoms in West Africa
founded about 1200 AD and survived until
the end of the sixteenth century and
there all of these religious scholars
who were pacifists within the Empire was
also something I was very very
interested in okay and let's define the
term jihad what do you mean by that
of course jihad is used in two special
ways in it
one way of defining jihad jihad and in
Arabic means struggle or effort the way
it's used in the Quran in chapter 9 of
the Quran it has a military militant
connotation religious scholars have
defined jihad as an internal struggle
kind of spiritual discipline an effort
to Center one's will in God and to be in
a very sort of strong moral position
visibly the attractions of the world and
spiritual jihad is actually called by
the scholars the greater jihad and the
military or militant jihad is called the
lesser jihad but I use it historically
I'm not really involved in a kind of
theological examination of the update of
the idea I'm entering the historical
uses of jihad in West African Islam ok
let's talk about the methodology how did
you do the research for the book well I
have to say that no one had written a
book on the subject before and when I
was in graduate school my thesis
director dissertation supervisor in
American language asked me if I knew
anything about this pacifist group in
African Islam I said no but I said no I
meant two things first I don't know them
and I'm not really sure I want to know
them because such a group sounds to me
incredulous I couldn't believe that
there was a pacifist movement anywhere
in Islam let alone in Africanist why is
that well because I was familiar with
the role of war and warfare in the
origins of Islam the famous book
Montgomery what road is called Mohammed
prophet and statesman and so my idea for
me growing up and learning about Islam
without Islam was both religion and
state and a political system and the
idea of pacifism
sort of begins to suggest that there was
some sort of separation between religion
and politics between church and state
and really I had no intellectual
foundation to grasp that idea at all
so that's why I was reluctant and also
incredulous at the idea so how did you
go about doing the research for the book
I discovered to my embarrassment that
actually I did know something about this
tradition I only denied it and
suppressed it so in the first place I
looked at what scholars may have written
about the subject mostly French and I
found a few articles scattered here and
there and some Western scholars who've
written about this particular group
called the Jahangir clerics as a kind of
commercial end clave and that again
struck me as a little bit odd because
they were really specialists in religion
and commerce was not their specialty
anyway I read up on that and then I went
to the archives went to Paris and looked
at the colonial archives and after all
of that I came back organized my notes
and then went into the field to do
research among the people themselves and
really there is no shortcut there is no
alternative to doing fieldwork to get to
know these people in this community
because that was the only way I really
could overcome my sort of reservations
about the subject where were you I'm
doing the fieldwork well I started in
Senegal and because the groups are based
really in Senegal and then I'm going to
Guinea but the main branch of the
community had moved from Guinea to
Senegal so I interviewed them in Senegal
and then when I was in Ghana I looked at
some of the archives Arabic manuscripts
and then I discovered an Arabic - script
that had been actually translated and
published in a journal in cano in
Nigeria so that was extremely helpful to
me
and so on in what way was it helpful
well because it showed it's a kind of
Arabic Chronicle that describes a branch
of these same people that I was studying
who had migrated from what today would
be money across tucano in Nigeria in the
15th century and that gave me the hint
that actually this is a very old ancient
community and I look at the two famous
chronicles that most historians know
about history of song-i two famous
chronicles and they also describe these
communities going back to the 15th
century and then I found a Portuguese
source
Tiago Gomez who wrote about this
community in the 1450s long before
Columbus Wow so I was really I felt okay
there's solid historical support for
really describing this community as a
clerical community dedicated to religion
opposed to war and warfare and unwilling
to be political rulers themselves
because you know today the words jihad
and Islam carries such a connotation of
violence and historically as you're
saying that's not the case how do you
think it evolved to get to that point
well I don't know I'm only speculating
here because I'm really pedestrian
historian political scientists would
have an angle on this which will be very
illuminating but I think in the 19th
century when the Muslim world after the
caliphate 1928 really the end of the
caliphate by which time the muslim world
had encountered colonial rule and
colonial rule organised the Muslim world
intonation States and at the end of the
Ottoman Caliphate in the 1920s
nation-states were created in the Arab
world Saudi Arabia for example
came into being and various Syria Iraq
and so these national state
jurisdictions elevated whole idea of
Islam to a political level and so it's
very easy I think in the 20th century
and 21st century for people to think Oh
Islam is politics and politics Islam and
I don't think that's really quite
accurate if you look at Sharia for
example which has a very bad name in the
West Sharia rule is intolerant and
bigoted and violent and cutting of limbs
and suppressing women Sharia
paradoxically was created founded by
scholars all of whom were persecuted by
the political rulers all of them and
they were all independent of politics
and the great law schools in Islam were
all independent of political dynasties
so this little group in West Africa
opened my eyes to the wider picture of
how Islam conceives of itself as a
religious mandate rather than as a
political construct so basically what
you conclude in your book what I
conclude in my book is that there is not
exactly a tradition of separation of
church and state in Islam because that's
going too far
there are no organized institutions
where religion belongs under the
leadership of religious masters and
politics belongs to another realm under
the leadership of political masters but
that there is a distinction in Islamic
thought between politics and religion
that political power is separated in
Islamic thought from religious authority
I mean religious authority really
depends on moral authority and moral
influence there is no Pope no Vatican in
Islam Islam is the least bureaucratic of
religions mosque don't have membership
lists until maybe recently and there is
no ordained clergy as such at least in
Sunni Islam
and so Islam strikes me as very
democratic in his view of the membership
of the community everyone is equal in
the eyes of God the law of God is the
same for everyone whether you're a king
or commoner ruler poor Rachel strong or
weak so it seems to me that this is very
compatible with the American idea of
religion as an institution of civil
society so that Islam belongs in civil
society more than it does in the state
and I think in conversations in America
we can appropriate some of these ideas
after all they created the founders of
the American Republic Jefferson John
Adams James Madison Benjamin Franklin
Thomas Jefferson they're all actually
we're aware of Islam and given America's
constitution of no prescription for
religion they said we would welcome a
Mufti from Constantinople really
Istanbul in our pulpit Benjamin Franklin
said they will be welcome in our meeting
house in Philadelphia Jefferson himself
welcomed Muslims in the White House so
it seems to me that if we get over the
present political hub and all this sort
of extreme rhetoric I think we can
appreciate how really this period of
Islam as a civil institution is not
incompatible with American ideas of
freedom of religion yes that would be
nice if that could happen if there was
one thing that you'd like people to take
away from reading your book what would
it be well the first thing I think I
would like people to take away
we are very political in America and
almost every idea we have we want to
sort of express it in political terms
but I think there is a case to be made
for understanding religion as a matter
of flag individual rights but really a
matter of the conscience
the great hairy gentleman in the Puritan
heritage really developed very strong
social institutions which describe
religion as a matter of individual
freedom of conscience in Islam I think
this idea is not so alien
you cannot worship God if you are
compelled to worship God because that's
really not worship anymore there's
something else and you can't love your
neighbour if you are on the dress now it
seems to me that civil society needs
values that the state cannot produce the
state can use those values but it cannot
produce them and so we have a
responsibility in religious communities
to train children in the ethics and the
virtues of truthfulness honesty hard
work concern and sensitivity to the
neighbour and so for and so on and those
are really civil values are not
necessarily state values this has been
very interesting thank you so much for
being here with us today and sharing
some of your work thank you very much
for having me I enjoy being here for
more information about professor sana
and his research please visit our
website at macmillan report yale.edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Centre for
International and area studies at Yale